Anish welcome to St Louis welcome to
grch tour part of your persona is
actually in social media and um you have
really individual and humorous tweets
and what do you think I mean what impact
social media uh have on chess players
life these days and um is it something
what you like to do or you're trying to
build in a way self brand through social
media yeah it's I no longer like
tweeting for a very long time but I
um
yeah I've sort of built
um some sort of a you know small chess
uh brand on online and um I I keep the
the fire burning there I think it's uh
it's been very helpful for me um I've
gotten a lot of more opportunities um
because of that and uh a lot of fans a
lot of support
so you know I'm not like Hikaru who uh
who is really going all out on uh on
streaming I I wasn't able to to do that
um but I still try to yeah have some
online presence but uh last year I been
focusing much more on the you know the
classical chess on the world
championship cycle and it's been very um
very exciting for me so I uh I hope to
finish this um season on on a high yeah
and speaking about the world
championship cycle and in general what's
happening on the top I know you always
have an opinion so can you just let's
say speak a little bit about what's
happening right now now last year with
Magnus who withdrew from the cycle with
dink who actually been absent for for a
long time with Hikaru who still actually
keeps playing quite well so like what's
happening right now what are the new
trends let's say no like as you
mentioned definitely very exciting times
in a sense I mean you've got Magnus who
is sort of um trying
to um not not not retire but uh at the
same
time yeah he's he's you know withdrawn
from certain things like the classical
uh World Championship cycle and also
he's choosing his events um in a
different way than usual and of course
yeah of course the fact that Ding after
his world championship title was wasn't
playing much that's also something
unusual and of course that hikaro is uh
uh at the very top after all these years
because he's been there for for many
many years and um it's only after he
sort of stopped playing professionally
as he as he says it that he you know
that his reason to S this High although
of course hiari he had his Peaks as well
before I think he won V tournament he
was 2800 at a given moment um but still
he sort of experiencing a second Peak
right now and that that's quite
remarkable and of we of course have also
a lot of youngsters um that are up and
coming but uh it isn't it isn't as easy
as as uh you would expect and many of
the youngsters they have uh risen and
but then theyve sort of Fallen back AIT
bit as you could see with lza with his
rating it went all the way to 2800 then
dropped a bit and you also have like
player like GES AB satov um they've sort
of went uh very quickly and entered the
top 10 even of also went very high but
then uh at some point um they weren't
able to keep up the momentum because of
course it's really hard to to stay at
the top so uh for a while they they drop
the rating a little bit back but I guess
they will keep um moving forward but
more than like two steps forwards one
step back kind of um kind of style so
yeah very exciting times uh and still
the players of Fabiano's generation are
doing very well Fabi himself and mostly
occasionally Maxim slamming the door
also very loudly in certain events
so I think a good time to be to be a
chess fan and uh uh also the the world
championship cycle is looking very
exciting so I'm I'm quite curious uh to
see also you got the you know the online
chess movement thing going so definitely
a special time to to be a chess fan
where do you see yourself on in this
circuit I yeah well you know I'm I'm a
social media
influencer doing uh doing my thing no
I'm I'm doing uh I'm happy with uh uh
yeah with with what I'm doing I'm um I
find playing CH very rewarding and uh
very challenging as well and
uh to an extent the fact that you know
I'm not as great as uh let's say Carlson
or some other players like it's it makes
it more fun for me to um to try because
you know I things don't come easy for me
and when I do have a good result I
really enjoy it thoroughly uh it's um
you know when it's so hard for you to to
achieve then whenever something good
happens I think the reward that you feel
is also higher
um I have some experience playing like
much weer tournaments um sometimes let's
say I played that championships uh when
the lineup was not very strong um and
then there a different kind of event
because you are under a lot of pressure
you you have to you have to win usually
you do win but of course it doesn't feel
as rewarding so there's not much to gain
so in in my chess career uh it's very
different because I have a lot to gain
always I'm not um you know world number
one or anything like that so there's a
lot of challenges for me and whenever I
achieve something local um I'm just
really really happy yeah I think it's a
really good moment to finish this
interview and wish you good luck in the
tournament thank
you